airstrikes have been carried out on
houthi-held territory in yemen all week
but this one was by far the most deadly
the main target seems to have been a
detention center in the houthi
stronghold of sada in northern yemen
the death toll continues to rise as they
find bodies many believe to be migrants
while searching for any survivors
the bombardment this week by the
saudi-led coalition follows a brazen
attack by the houthis using drones on
the capital of the united arab emirates
abu dhabi on monday which killed three
people
in new york at the u.n the security
council met behind closed doors to
discuss that attack but not the attacks
on houthi-controlled areas the current
president of the council is norway i
asked its ambassador mona jul for her
country's reaction to the scale of the
death toll in saddar
it's it's not acceptable and
and we
absolutely
call for uh for restraints on on all
side day after the meeting the
ambassador of the united arab emirates
flanked by representatives of six other
council members including the permanent
members the uk france and the us
gave a statement that this egregious
aggression by the houthis as well as the
proliferation of missile and other
technology that enabled the terrorist
attack she made no mention of the sadat
attack by the coalition of which the uae
is one of the two main members so i
pressed the ambassador your defense
under law has to be proportionate does
it not and the president of the council
norway speaking in a national
capacity said the attack that took place
in sadat was unacceptable what you have
heard today
and you will know following the work of
the council that this is rare what you
have heard today is the unanimous
condemnation by the security council
against the terrorist attack against the
united arab emirates on monday the 17th
of january i'm not asking you about that
i'm asking about your response and
whether it was proportionate given that
at least 60 people have died maybe as
many as i'd like to refer you to the
coalition statement on that matter but
i'd also like to affirm here that the
coalition undertakes to abide by
international law and proportionate
response in all its military operations
human rights groups have criticized the
security council's approach as one-sided
the council did issue a statement but
again only on the drone attack on abu
dhabi the secretary general of the
united nations antonio guterres has
addressed the carnage in siddhar and
other attacks in houthi-controlled areas
he's called for prompt effective and
transparent investigations james bay's
al-jazeera at the united nations